it feels like just the other day that
you had to believe all women because
women never lie
there's different that way biologically
now you can't acknowledge that because
no one can define what a woman is not
even people who want to sit on a supreme
court and if you try to define them you
will get in big trouble we for example
are still locked out of our twitter
account
for affirming the obvious biological sex
is real it's said at birth no one in
human history has ever doubted that
because it's true
but some people are still willing to say
that we showed you this clip the other
night it shows one woman watching as
leah thomas who is a man wins a women's
swimming competition watch this
i'm a woman that is
not a wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
so we said we're going to try and find
the woman who said that and we did her
name is kelly j keane she's a founder of
standing for women and we're happy to
have her join us tonight
thank you so much for coming on kelly j
king so oh thank you so much
so you're not afraid to say what's true
why are you not afraid
oh i think it's my duty i think because
i because it needs to be said
i'm 100 sure that that i have to say it
um
there's many people that are afraid that
are in positions where they feel they're
going to lose their jobs but
we can't all be silent otherwise the
world is is going fast to uh helena
hancock
i think that's exactly yeah handcart i
think that's exactly that's exactly
right but why is this important i mean
there are a lot of fake things going on
people lie all the time you've taken a
stand on this specific issue how come
well i think if you can no longer define
what a woman is we can't talk about
women
our language is being diluted uh all
over the place in the uk and i'm sure in
the us uh women are called cervix havers
menstruators chest feeders birthing
persons uh so we have to give up the
language that describes us um but
the you know if the only people that are
allowed to be called women these days
are actually men
so this seems i mean you know far be it
for me to weigh in on what it must feel
like as a woman but it does seem
degrading
to be called the haver i mean what
it is ultimately
really sexist like the most pernicious
sexism uh that's what's happening
to women all over the world
so why aren't people who say they have
the interests of women at heart standing
up and saying no you can't pretend that
being a woman is as simple as changing
your clothes
this i've
thought about long and hard i think it
comes to cowardice
i think it comes to cult-like mentality
i think these people are brainwashed um
they are experiencing truckloads of
cognitive dissonance i talked to many
girls outside of the swimming pool
who you know you said the question like
what is a woman and
they literally would not speak
it's really sinister
well it is sinister because it seems
like the biggest and best organized
bullying campaign against a population
ever organized did anybody at the meet
say wait a second that's cheating this
man is cheating because that's what it
is
i don't think anyone dared say it
which is why i really felt i had to say
something there was just this oppressive
silence on everybody knew that there was
a man in the pool
racing with the girls
everybody knew it and those that knew it
wouldn't say it um but the person in
front of me was quite happy to say
that uh he was definitely a woman
so it's it's just really scary this is
why those of us and it's fantastic that
you um
talk about this quite a lot tucker
because so many other broadcasters are
simply too afraid
yeah i mean i you know i could care less
how you dress or what you call yourself
but this is not liberation this is the
dark ages and you have remained cheerful
and honest in the middle of it and i
really admire that i appreciate you
coming on tonight kelly j king thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else